all right guys dominant here for Kit
Guru and we are back with the first of
many GPU launches for 2025 things are
kicking off with Intel's Arc b570 which
is of course the smaller sibling to the
b580 that we reviewed back in December
alongside its reduced specifications the
b570 also Sports A reduced price
targeting a $219 MSRP making this one of
the cheapest gpus that we have reviewed
in years but exactly what can it bring
to the table at that price point and
just how much slower is it than the 214
b580 all that and more is covered in
today's
[Music]
review announced alongside the b580 the
b570 that we are reviewing today is more
or less the same thing but it's just
been cut back slightly in a few key
areas and that has allowed Intel to drop
the price by 12 % targeting the $219
MSRP whereas the b580 fetches a $30
premium that being said pricing and
availability remains a pretty big
problem for the b580 as I've not been
able to find it for less than
£290 here in the UK despite the fact it
launched at
£249 as such that means prices for the
b570 have also CED up and right now I've
not been able to find it listed for
pre-order for any less than 250 brick
richest pounds to quickly recap the spec
though the b570 is very similar to the
b580 and that is built on the same BMG
g21 silicon but just strip back in a few
key areas it has two fewer XE calls for
instance with a total of 18 while it has
144 x max engines and tmus down from 160
on the b580 graphics clock speed is also
reduced at 2,500 MHz while there's a
cutback memory system too with 10 gigs
of gdr 6 memory operating at 19 GBS
second over a 160 bit interface and that
gives total memory bandwidth at 380 GB a
second given those cutbacks it does make
sense that power dry is also lower rated
at 150 W tbp compared to 190 wats for
the b580 for my testing today then I am
using our brand new GPU test system that
is powered by MSI and if you want to
learn more about this I did actually
make a full video on it earlier this
week so I'll leave a link to that down
in the description below it is however
packing in the ryzen 79800 x3d the MSI
MPG x870 carbon Wi-Fi motherboard and
there's 64 gigs of Kingston Fury Beast
ddr5 6,000 megat transfers cl30 memory
by now you've probably also realized
that we don't have one of Intel's
limited edition models for review today
as they're not actually making them for
the b570 instead we were sent the ASRock
Challenger aftermarket card which I'll
be using for all testing today it's also
worth saying that I am focusing on 1080p
for the data in this video I will touch
on 1440p for the game games where it was
possible but I think 1080p is the
realistic use case for a GPU of this
caliber however if you do want to see
1080P 1440p and even 4K every single one
of our Benchmark charts is over on the
full review on kit guru.net and again
I'll leave a link to that down in the
description below kicking off then with
Allen wake 2 at 1080p the b570 delivers
37 FPS using the high preset and that
makes it 11% slower than both the b580
and the RTX 4060 it's also dead level
with the Alchemist a770 and just a frame
faster than the RTX 360 12 GB 1440p
gaming though isn't really possible at
these settings as we only saw 25 FPS on
average and even worse 1% lows so you
definitely want to enable upscaling or
drop down to something like the low
preset for Allen wake 2 moving on to
Blackmouth Wukong though this one
appears to be something of a problem for
the battle mage family given the b570 is
actually second bottom in our chart it
only managed 22 FPS on average and
granted it is a highly demanding game
but that still makes it slower than even
the arc a750 so I'm really not sure
what's going on here cyberpunk 2077
however is a much better experience on
the b570 we average 74 FPS at 1080p
using ultra settings with no upscaling
and that makes it 12% slower than the
b580 it's also 7% faster than amd's RX
7600 and it's about level of the RTX 460
so that is pretty good going for this C
of GPU 1440p is also very playable in
cyberpunk with an average just below 50
FPS and now the b570 is 11% faster than
the RX 7600 while it's actually level
with the 7600 XD and Intel a770 moving
on to Final Fantasy 16 this is a new
addition to our test suite and it is
incredibly GPU heavy with the b570
managing just 29 FPS on average at 1080p
that puts it squarely between the a750
and the a 770 while it's 9% slower than
the b580 fora Horizon 5 is next and this
remains an incredibly well optimized
title so it's really no surprise to see
the b570 hitting 83 FPS at 1080p extreme
settings putting it level with the a770
and the RX 7600 it's 14% slower than the
b580 here and only 8% behind the RTX
4060 1440p gaming is also no problem in
this title this time it's still
averaging 70 frames per second so that's
highly impressive performance and that
savages the b570 between the a770 and
the RX 7600 ghost of sushima is another
title that runs very well on battle mage
at least it does now after the initial
stuttering issues were fixed last month
at 10p though the b570 hits 64 FPS on
average putting it just behind the RTX
460 ti no less a hugely impressive
result considering the price difference
even at 1440p it's still managing 49 FPS
yes using the very high preset once
again putting it level with the 46ti
while it's 16% slower than the ark b580
as for Horizon forbidden West with an
average of 57 FPS the b570 is once again
10% slower than the b580 though that's
still very impressive considering it is
basically matching the performance of
the 7600 XT and the RTX 4060 both of
which are a good chunk more expensive
even gaming at 1440p is solid enough for
Horizon forbidden West with the b570
hitting 45 FPS but get this the b570 is
now a whopping 24% faster than the RTX
4060 which I believe is due to
insufficient vram on the GeForce GPU so
that 10 GB frame buffer for the b570 is
clearly well worth having as for the
Last of Us Part One here the b570 is
capable of hitting 50 FPS on average at
1080p once again savaging it between the
7600 and the RTX 460 while it's 16%
slower than the b580 but 11% faster than
the a770 the b570 is also very closely
matched to the a770 in a plagu tale
requium but it has substantially better
1% lows which is really good to see it's
also 6% behind the RX 7600 when looking
at the 1080p data when looking at the
1440p data I'd say it's just about
manageable but we're only looking at
Circa 30 FPS performance so you
definitely want to enable upscaling or
do a few image quality tweaks moving on
though I do think the evidence suggests
that battle mage does struggle with
Unreal Engine 5 Games as again we can
see the b570 fall off inua Saga
hellblade 2 at 1080p it is right down
the bottom of the chart slower than even
the RTX 3060 and it's actually a hair
behind the a770 as well moving on though
to Starfield and in terms of the average
frame rate the b570 does relatively well
here coming in ahead of both the RTX 460
and RX 7600 by single digit margins the
1% lows are more of a struggle however
coming in worse than either of those two
gpus which isn't an issue we can see
with Intel's Alchemist gpus so I do
think some work could be done there to
improve things in that regard there's no
such issue in Total War Warhammer 3
however at 1080p the b570 is absolutely
flying with 84 FPS on average once again
putting it 14% behind the b580 but it's
within touching distance of the 7600 and
RTX 460 at 1440p as well we still get a
very solid 56 frames per second on
average putting the b570 within just 1%
of the RX
[Music]
7600 that is it for our per game
benchmarks then and now we're going to
move on to look at the big picture with
our 12 game average over the 12 games we
tested then the arc b570 managed an
average frame rate of 51 FPS at 1080p
that makes it 133% slower than the b580
it's 5% behind the RTX 4060 but dead
level with amds RX 7600 it's also just a
hair ahead of the last generation a770
while it comes in 12% faster on average
than the RTX 36d 12 GB as for 1440p
obviously the frame rate is much lower
here and there are plenty of games where
you need to either drop down to lower
image quality settings or enable
upscaling for a playable experience but
on average here it's 15% behind the b580
it's 5% faster than the RX 7600 and
barely 2% slower than the RTX 4060 as
for what that data means in terms of the
Cosa frame analysis then I'm going to
first start by looking at the MSRP in US
given there's actually no official UK
MSRP in British Pounds what we can see
when looking at this data though is a
value proposition that is very similar
to the b580 the b570 turns out to be 12%
cheaper and 133% slower that sounds
reasonable enough and it is still right
at the top of the chart but I personally
do think Intel needs to be a bit more
aggressive with the b570 is pricing we'd
actually expect better value at the
lower price here and we have to remember
the b570 has 2 gigs less vram as well
and as it happens things actually look
worse when we look at the current retail
pricing this time in GBP right now the
b570 cannot be found for pre-order for
less than
£250 which is simply too much it
actually makes the value proposition
worse than the RX 7600 and RTX 4060
which I really don't think is a position
that Intel can compete from moving on
though to look at rage racing
performance I'm going to start off with
Alan Wake 2 here we are actually using
quality upscaling but even then you're
not going to be enabling the high preset
for R racing in this game it is simply
way too much for this class of GPU to
handle with the b570 barely hitting 20
FPS on average Blackmouth Wukong is even
worse this game is clearly designed to
be played with an Nvidia GPU and the
b570 Falls well down the chart averaging
just 13 FPS again even with quality
upscaling enabled thankfully cyberpunk
2077 is much more performant for the
b570 though do know I'm not using path
tracing here but rather using the ult
preset at 108p with no upscaling enabled
with that in mind we're looking at 32
FPS on average which is okay it would be
better if you did enable upscaling but
without it the b570 absolutely crushes
even amd's RX 7600 XT I did however
still encounter frequent hard locks as
we found during our b580 testing so this
is still an issue for Intel to fix and
it renders the game I'd say pretty much
unplayable with these RT settings
enabled as we just just ran into hard
loock after hard loock after hard loock
next up though is f124 and we do get
playable frame rates at 1080p though
we're not exactly flying at 36 FPS on
average still that is much better than
what the AMD RX 7600 is able to manage
but Intel can't match the RTX 3060 here
it is however very good to see that the
frame times have been significantly
improved since the launch of the b580
here we're looking at a frame time plot
comparing the b580 using its launch
driver from December to the b570 using
its own launch driver from this month
and aside from a couple of small frame
time spikes it is a very consistent
experience for the b570 so credit must
go to Intel for fixing that issue I did
however go back and try to retest the
b580 with this new driver to see if the
fix would also work on that GPU but no
matter what I tried the game didn't seem
to want to render in all I could see was
the HUD so clearly there is more work
still to be done likewise ratchet in
clang remains completely broken on
battle mage gpus the b570 proved even
worse than the b580 and it was a
stuttery mess the whole time barely
getting above 10 FPS interestingly
though when looking at the GPU power
draw in this game I noticed it was very
low for the b570 barely hitting 60 or 70
Watts perhaps suggesting there's some
sort of bandwidth issue at play as the
GPU is being starved but it's hard to
say for sure thankfully returnal plays
much much better and it's a genuinely
good experience with maxed out rate
racing at 1080p admittedly it does only
have two rate raced effects being
shadows and Reflections but nearly 60
FPS on average is still a very solid
result for the b570 given it's actually
about level with nvidia's RTX 460 shadow
of the Tomb Raider plays as well as
you'd expect given it's over 6 years old
at this point and only features rate
race Shadows even then the fact that the
b570 is level with the more expensive RX
7600 XT really shows you the potential
for the battle mage architecture when it
comes to rate racing lastly I'm going to
close out with Star Wars Outlaws a game
where I unfortunately still experience
regular crashing with battle mage gpus
when I was able to play the game
performance is actually decent about
level with the RX 7600 But it's still
sub 30 FPS so you would want to enable
upscaling that is if you can actually
run the game longer than 5 minutes
overall rate tracing performance then is
not as impressive as what we saw from
the b580 granted the abysmal performance
in Ratchet and Clank does pull the
average down but we're still looking at
the b570 coming in 21% slower on average
than its bigger sibling now that still
means the b570 is actually on par with
the RX 7600 XT a GPU that is again a
good chunk more expensive and it's
really not far off the performance of
the RTX 362 GB time to hit pause on
those game benchmarks however and take a
little bit of time just to look closely
at the ack Challenger card its design
and then we're going to look at Thermals
acoustic sticks and power drawer the
card itself is a relatively conventional
design it has a black plastic shroud
that's accented with some reflective
areas alongside the Challenger branding
it's obviously a dual fan unit and each
fan measures approximately 100 mm in
diameter as for Dimensions the
Challenger is a little bit bigger than
the b580 limited edition but it's still
a compact dual slot card coming in at
249 by 132 by 41 mm the front side of
the card is home to the azrock and Intel
Arc logos plus there's a small bluish
greenish LED strip which you can
actually toggle on or off via the switch
at the end of the PCB ASRock has also
fitted a metal back blade to the card
which I love to see and this features a
large flowthrough cutout to allow air to
pass directly through the heat sink
power is supplied by a single eight pin
connector and we find three display port
2.1 and one HDMI 2.1 video connectors do
know however that only the middle
display port is rated for uhb 13.5
bandwidth while the others are rated at
uhb 10 the looking for a new chair then
definitely go and check out
b.co they offer a whole host of gaming
and office chairs that come in a variety
of different finishes and different
colors as for our thermal results then
I've obviously only tested the one b570
card for launch so I've also included
the b580 limited edition here just as a
reference point it's not a direct
comparison as the b570 draws less power
but it just gives you an idea in any
case the b570 Challenger is a very
competent design with the GPU core
hitting just 60° while the GPU Global
and vram metrics topped out at 66° so
absolutely nothing to worry about in
fact what makes that thermal performance
even more impressive is that the
Challenger ran so quietly underload in
my testing the fans did not spin up past
1080 RPM so the noise didn't even
register on my sound meter it is that
quiet and clearly indicates that the
cooler design is way overkill for this
level of power not that I'm complaining
speaking speak of power draw for this we
actually use nvidia's Pat tool to
measure power draw of the graphics card
only on a per game per resolution basis
that means for every single game we test
at every single resolution we also plot
power draw so I won't go over every
single one of those charts in this video
otherwise we'd be here for hours and
hours but if you do want to see all of
that power testing you can find it in
the written review on kit g.net instead
in this video I'm going to be focusing
on the average of all 12 games tested at
1080p just as a reminder Intel States a
total board power of 150 wats for the
b570 but just as we found with the b580
in practice the actual power draw is
much lower averaged over the 12 games I
tested the Challenger Drew 132.0 Watts
making it a very low power GPU indeed
now you can already tell that the Nvidia
gpus are more efficient considering the
RTX 460 TI draws a similar amount of
power yet is a good chunk faster but
it's hardly a horrible amount of power
draw for the b570 now we're going to
look at performance per watt a simple
calculation where we divide frame rate
by the power draw for each game and then
present the average result here as it
turns out the b570 is just as efficient
as the b580 putting it on a similar
level to something like amd's RX 7700 XT
that means it is a really solid
improvement over The Alchemist series
delivering exactly 50% more performance
per watt compared to the a750 it does
however still lag behind Nvidia and the
rtx4 series here and it be really
interesting to see if Nvidia can make
further gains with the upcoming 50
Series cards just like the b580 as well
idle power draw is still on the high
side hovering around 32 watts in my
testing but you can enable the same sort
of fix to reduce it first you need to
make sure that aspm is enabled in the
Bios and then go into the control panel
and tweak the power settings
specifically the PCI Express link state
power management option choosing maximum
power savings for me this did show an
immediate drop in idle power but it was
still higher than expected at around 22
Watts even after letting it sit for a
bit so it does help but it won't get you
down to the likes of the RTX 460 which
Isles at around 8 to 10 watts so that
brings us to the end of this review and
I think it's fair to say that most of
the focus around the battle mage Series
has gone onto the b580 with the b570
kind of flying under the radar somewhat
but as it turns out it is a capable
graphics card for 1080p gaming that said
I do actually think there would be more
excitement for the b570 if it actually
launched before the b580 that's because
fundamentally this is a $220 graphics
card that is trading blows with the
likes of the RX 7600 and RTX 460 while
also offering more vram considering that
both of those competitors are a good
chunk more expensive than the b570 at
least in terms of the launch MSRP and
Intel is definitely coming out favorably
in those comparisons which is really
good news it's when we look at the b570
in relation to the b580 however that
things start to get murky as it turns
out in my testing the b570 is 133%
slower on average at 1080p despite being
just 12% cheaper and shipping with 2
gigs less vram for me that's just not
enough of a price difference for the
b570 to be able to etch out its own
niche in the market it's not like the
b570 is bad value as it's still right at
the top of our crossw frame chart but I
think with another $20 locked off the
price it would make more sense relative
to its faster and more expensive sibling
complicating things further is the fact
that right now the b570 cannot be
pre-ordered for less than
£250 here in the UK and that only
worsens the value proposition for this
card amd's RX 7600 for instance can be
found for just 230 quid at the time of
filming or RTX 46d starts from about
£255
yes both of those are only 8 GB cards
but I firmly believe Intel must offer a
decent discount relative to its
competition for its gpus to have appeal
simply because it's much more of a risk
buying a battle mage GPU than it is
something from AMD or Nvidia and right
now based on these UK prices that is
simply not happening there are of course
still driver complaints to be had around
this series of gpus as I showed earlier
in the video however In fairness to
Intel things have actually improved a
fair bit from the launch of the b580
already so of the 18 games I tested I
only had three giving me issues and
incidentally they were all ones with
rate tracing enabled so of the 12 games
where I only looked at rized performance
I did not encounter any driver bugs so
that is definitely good news for Intel
and its battle mage series of gpus new
issues have come to light since then
however with testing from both hardware
conect and Hardware unbox revealing
batter Mage performance can drop off
significantly when paired with an older
C GPU we've just upgraded to a new 9800
x3d test system so I've been really busy
rebenchmarking all of our gpus so I've
not been able to test that for myself
yet but I did put the question to Intel
and they gave me the following statement
we Intel are aware of reports of
performance sensitivity in some games
when paired with older generation
processors and we are investigating
considering just how far Intel's
Alchemist series of gpus have come since
their launch in October 2022 I do remain
100% confident that Intel will continue
to improve the battle maze Series right
now however I'm just still not ready to
be able to fully recommend these gpus
given the issues just laid down the b570
as well I think really could benefit
from a price adjustment just to help it
step out from the b580 shadow as at its
core it is a very capable entry-level
GPU and I'm optimistic it is one that's
going to get better with time anyway
guys that is going to do it for this
video if you liked it please toss me a
thumbs up and as always let me know your
thoughts down in the comments below
please do subscribe if you haven't
already and be sure to ding that
notification Bell so you don't miss when
we upload a new video if you want to
carry on the conversation you can find
an invite link to our Discord server
down in the description and while you're
there you can help us out by picking up
a t-shirt from our merch tour such as
the ones you can see on screen right now
lastly if you're feeling particularly
generous you can even consider backing
us on patreon but that's it for me guys
I'm Dominic for Kit Guru and I'll see
you in the next video